our entrepreneur and investor being
imported for ten years and I kind of got
a bit lucky and properties went up into
hair is already financed but awful folio
not from a wealthy family or anything
which caught people's attention
sure Cordy years ago it's like vlogging
can I talk to Jay and and helping people
within their pop you jelly which is just
really really blowing up I've got quite
a big following are they're advertised
at all it's all organic
from the Facebook group YouTube
advertising you're doing the best yeah
yeah totally I mean it's super important
especially real estate to not talk about
it as luck but to accept it for what it
is yeah I'm not saying that there isn't
luck
yeah that's not where I'm going
realistic is very basic yeah it's
extremely up and extremely down yeah
what what happened was your timing yes
in your benefit yeah and the basically
saying latkes reason you're diversifying
is you know that it's not sustainable
so what happens next on the market goes
down well here's the thing please that
because people say oh well the property
line Dallas breakfast it and as
Destiny's challah I'm a property on
Japan that I'm not property investor
yeah I'm done for now understood but
that's great you go from broker job
making actual investments yeah that's
your definition not actively of a
property on support yeah being a broker
in the beginning and reinvesting
potentially yes these people say yeah
people saying like all I can't do
because of this on it is this on bump
you put myself in the worst possible
position and doing it and there's
different ways
Mercury's warm over there motivation
memo new policy so I'm going to
demonstrate that
but you didn't demonstrated by brokering
a deal getting the profits and
reinvesting in security yeah okay
[Music]
[Music]